today on the matt walsh show burger king
and nickelodeon have come out especially
aggressively this month to push radical
far left lgbt propaganda
both of these companies though would be
bankrupted tomorrow if conservatives
responded by refusing to ever patronize
them again like we should
but that won't happen why is that we'll
talk about that also five headlines
including the ceo of pfizer
says that children don't really need the
vaccine but they're gonna be testing it
on kids anyway for the sake of
protecting
adults isn't that completely backwards
and chris harrison of the bachelor has
officially lost his job
after groveling and apologizing to the
mob despite having done nothing wrong so
that same old story again and finally in
our daily cancellation
national geographic has a message for
whitey be ashamed
be very ashamed we'll discuss that and
much more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
one of the newer traditions of pride
month is the perpetual redesign
of the pride flag every year more colors
are added to it
as more identities and sexualities sneak
their way into the lgbt club
at this point the rainbow has become
less a rainbow and more of a
random chaotic assortment of contrasting
colors
as ben shapiro put it the pride flag now
looks like a cat vomited and then looked
at the vomit through a kaleidoscope
now media matters was upset with ben for
that description
by the way but and i was upset too
mainly because i didn't think of it
anyway our dear friends over at pink
news helped to unveil the new pride flag
which um which you can see you notice
that the traditional rainbow
and then you know we know about that and
then there are these other colors that
are sort of jutting out
literally and figuratively pushing the
traditional rainbow out of view
the newer colors are meant to represent
trans people
and also black and brown people now you
might ask why
black and brown people need their own
colors on the flag it's not as though
the original colors
were representative of anyone's specific
race wasn't it supposed to be for all
races
there's purple was on the original pride
like there are no purple
people running around out there as far
as i know though if anyone identifies as
purple then of course i'll respect that
self-identity
the whole thing doesn't make sense but
then making sense has never been a
specialty
of lgbt activists what makes the least
sense of all
is the yellow triangle on the new flag
with a purple circle
which is meant to represent intersex
people my point is not that the symbol
is nonsensical though it is
but that the inclusion of intersex
people on a pride flag at all
is nonsensical putting intersex people
under the lgbt umbrella
including them in the acronym lgbtqi
i think uh we're up to a
so on and so on but it makes no logical
sense intersex is a medical
condition it's a birth defect
it's a con congenital disorder intersex
is when someone is born with ambiguous
genitalia
or genitalia that has an appearance that
doesn't match with their biological sex
this again is a medical condition it has
a medical cause
lots of times when a child is born this
way
you can figure out what the cause was
it's not a mystery
it's not an orientation it's not a
lifestyle choice it's not a chosen
identity it has absolutely nothing to do
with being gay or trans or anything
you might as well include diabetics and
people with food allergies on the flag
so why are intersex people being lumped
in this way the answer is that they are
useful to the trans agenda
it's the only reason they're there trans
activists will often use intersex people
as a way to just to prove that sex is
non-binary
when you hear this all the time right
what do you mean what about intersect oh
you think that
there's only males and females what
about intersex huh
and if they they think if they can use
intersex people to prove that sex is
non-binary that would
uh you know validate the transgender
identity the problem is that intersex
people do not prove that sex is
non-binary they only prove that physical
anomalies exist
just as people born with one arm don't
disprove the statement
that humans have two arms and besides
whatever they prove or don't prove they
do nothing to validate the claims of a
biological male
with a fully male body who claims to be
a woman
it's a totally different thing the
inclusion of intersex people into this
whole discussion is nothing but
obfuscation it's dissembling
they should make the circle into a
shield because that's what the intersex
condition is
for lgbt activists it's something they
can hide behind
but that is all somewhat irrelevant to
the point in hand
getting to the point and for a more
thorough explanation of the pride flag
we can now turn again to nickelodeon
which enlisted a drag queen to explain
the pride flag to children
if this sounds like a rerun from last
week if you're saying well did we just
do this last week
we did um nickelodeon had the drag queen
nina west
sing a song about gay pride on blues
clues
uh a show for preschoolers just a few
days ago
now west is back and cross-dressing
again to
perform another gay pride song for
preschoolers
and i will now subject you to a small
portion of it you're welcome here it
[Music]
every is in lgbtq plus is equal and
black and brown represents the queer and
trans people of color
doesn't it just fill you with pride
showing who you are
[Music]
red light orange healing yellow is
sunlight
green nature blue purple is smearing
baby blue
pink white represent transgender people
and black and brown
represent the queer and trans people of
color
[Music]
we're all in this together so wave that
pride flag
go big be kind be you
an appropriately bad and ugly song about
a hideously ugly flag
and that's the only thing i can call
appropriate here by the way the drag
queen's real name
i should mention is andrew levitt
and i'll show you what he looks like in
real life
um and the only reason i want to show
you that is in order for is so that you
know
you know okay well there's andrew levitt
right there um
nina west i mean this this is a guy
who's made it his mission now
to sing about transgenderism and
pansexuality to preschoolers
that's his mission in life apparently
but in order for levitt to go from what
you see in this photo to what you saw in
the video
he must appropriate womanhood in the
most demeaning and cartoonish way
imaginable
as i've argued many times drag queens
are an example a rather garish in your
face example
of actual appropriation these men are
making caricatures
out of womanhood if a white guy in
dreads is somehow appropriating from
black people even though white guys have
been wearing dreads for millennia
then certainly a man with fake breasts a
wig a dress a female stage name etc
is appropriating from women but they get
away with it because drag is associated
with lgbt identities
and lgbt stand at the top of the victim
hierarchy even though these are
the least oppressed and most celebrated
people in society hands down
as for the fact that this was on
nickelodeon i have frequently discussed
the issue of the sexual indoctrination
of children this obviously is another
case of that
nickelodeon is not at all hiding its
agenda
okay that's the point they're not shy
about it they have announced to the
world with parades literally and
fireworks and trumpets blaring that they
wish to indoctrinate very young children
into far-left radicalism
they wish to introduce concepts like
pansexuality and transgenderism
to your three-year-old they wish for
your three-year-old to actually adopt
one of those identities and they're
going to try to make that happen
they're not being coy about this it's
right there in the open
but here's the sad thing and it's also
the reason conservatives are losing the
culture war
i can guarantee many conservative
parents
even after being made aware of this will
still allow their children to watch the
network
after all this i mean they put out two
videos of a drag queen
pushing transgenderism etc on
preschoolers
in the span of a week and yet still many
parents who rightly object to that kind
of content
will not prevent their children from
being exposed to it
worse they will justify their laziness
and neglect on the basis of principle
they'll claim that it goes against their
conservative principles
to boycotts or to engage in cancel
culture
even if they're canceling quote-unquote
cancelling
major corporations that are trying to
brainwash and corrupt
their own children these are the same
people who probably will still eat at
burger king
um although burger king put out a tweet
yesterday taking a shot at chick-fil-a
and announcing that and the shot at
chick-fil-a who cares
uh what i do care about is that they
announced they'll make a donation to the
human rights campaign
for every chicken sandwich they sell
now i've been to burger king maybe twice
in 15 years
and both times to use the bathroom on a
long drive you know
uh burger king is good for that at least
there might have been one other occasion
at an airport when they were the only
place open but that's about it because
the food is trash
that is unless you enjoy soggy french
fries and hamburgers that are made eight
hours ahead of time then zapped bun and
mayo
and everything in the microwave right
before serving it that's why when you
uh when you do get burger king
everything is piping hot including the
mayo itself is like scalding hot
like molten lava because they put
everything in the microwave
it's hard for me to believe that anyone
eats at burger king regularly and on
purpose but apparently people do
and again the sad thing is that people
still
will eat there after this conservatives
included
they have just told us that they will
take our money
if you give it to them they will take it
and they will give some of it to the
human rights campaign
which is a radical far-left militant
organization
if you eat at burger king now you're not
only playing russian roulette with food
poisoning
but you are directly giving to one of
the most radically leftist advocacy
organizations in existence
and yet burger king probably will not
see a massive drop-off in sales as every
conservative decides
to spend their money elsewhere that's
what's so sad
and pathetic burger king
would be bankrupted if every
conservative stopped eating there
nickelodeon would also be put under if
every conservative parent stopped
allowing their children to watch it
but that's probably not what's going to
happen and that's why we lose
if we want to win we have to start
playing for keeps
we have to make these companies pay a
price
we have to decide what exactly we're
conserving as conservatives that's the
classic question i know for me
i am most i can answer that question uh
what do i want to conserve i want to
conserve moral decency
sanity truth
as a parent first and foremost i want to
conserve my own children's
souls and innocence
if you're not focused on conserving any
of that
then i just don't know whose side you're
on exactly
and whatever side it is we aren't on the
same one
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
now we check in with our sponsors over
at ar 500
armor you know one thing i've been
thinking a lot about especially recently
i've always had this on my mind but
it's been on my mind even more recently
is about the need
and responsibility that i have to keep
my family safe
and that's uh one great advantage of the
second amendment that's one thing the
second amendment
enables us to do and you've heard me
share about how important second
amendment is to the foundation of our
country
and how preparing yourself is so
important
and body armor is also a part of that
i'd recommend you check out ar
500 armor they have loadouts designed
for
everyone whether you need a concealable
vest for daily use
a plate carrier for the range or a fully
equipped setup for the worst case
scenario whatever it is they've got it
all you just got to go and check it out
for yourself
our friends at ar500 armor have made
buying body armor easy approachable and
affordable
and if you're unsure of what type of
armor you're needing or you just need
some pointers or whatever it is
they've got you covered on that as well
so they're very helpful
and they're gonna they're gonna give you
what you need so go to ar
500 armor dot com slash walsh to see all
their promotions and special pricing
running right now you can use code walls
for 20 off anything else in their entire
store best of all
they put together some packages
specifically for listeners of the daily
wire so there's something for everyone
at ar 500 armor
visit ar500 armor dot com slash wall
should use code wall should check out
for 20
off speaking of the innocence of
children does anyone i don't know if
this is a thing
uh if this is a normal thing with kids
because i only have my own kids
but my kid is this is other parents do
you have this where uh see my kids will
wake up
in the morning very early
and start singing
they bounce they're literally bouncing
off the walls and singing at about 6 a.m
i left the house this morning all right
i got around 6am
and i heard my son upstairs and like he
had just woken up himself and he's
already
singing it's like i'm living in it's
like the von trapp family
sound of music and i'm not a morning
person at all
but that's that's my kids and i can kind
of see i
i remember being a kid myself vaguely
and i can remember i i remember as
christmas was really the day
when i would wake up at the all of us
you know and my siblings wake up at the
crack of dawn
or pounding on my parents door wake up
wake up come on it's time
and they're just grunting at us like
grizzly bears yeah i gotta go
it's too early i remember doing that on
christmas and and birthdays special
occasions
my kids do that every day
every day
but you know what they sort of said it's
innocence it's they're they're just
so excited that's what makes it kind of
sad because i think why am i not the
same way
they are so excited to be awake as soon
as they wake up it'll be 5
30 and they're just ready to go let's go
it's time
another day singing joyously
before the sun rises
um it's uh it's it's very cute but it's
also
uh incredibly annoying
okay let's go number one here
the chairman and ceo of pfizer albert
borla
he tweeted this yesterday he says
although data shows that severe kova 19
is rare in children
widespread vaccination is a critical
tool to help stop transmission that's
why i'm excited we have begun dosing
participants
aged 5 to 11 in a global phase
2 3 study of the pfizer
vaccine just the phrase i'm excited
we've begun
dosing participants age 5 to 11.
that is creepy enough i'm excited we
started dosing them
he continues this is an essential study
to help further evaluate the vaccine and
if safety
and immunogenicity in this age group is
confirmed
protect our communities and children
aged 5 to 11. we're grateful for the
enthusiasm we have been seeing
in response to the trial we couldn't
advance this work without courageous
volunteers
courageous volatility who are the
courageous volunteers
what do you mean courageous the kids
aren't volunteering
they don't know a five-year-old are you
call i hope we're not calling a
five-year-old a
volunteer they have no idea if there's
they have no idea what they're
volunteering for
all they know is that after this thing
happens they get a lollipop and a
sticker that
they're volunteering for a lollipop and
a sticker that's what they're
volunteering for
um the possibility of side effects and
everything else they don't know anything
about that
so no it's the parents who are
volunteering them
[Music]
to volunteering to take this dose
to help the drug company confirm
the safety of the shot for kids
conf meaning we haven't confirmed that
it's safe
yet we haven't confirmed that this drug
is safe
for kids yet hey parents do you want to
line your kids up and we'll uh shoot it
into their arms and see what happens
to help us confirm the safety
so who are the courageous ones the
parents
the parents are courageously
putting their own kids health on the
line
is that courageous for them it's not
them it's their kid
this to me is so backwards and uh and
just wrong
and infuriating you know why are you've
got the ceo
of pfizer who is saying
the cover 19 rare covenant or
rather severe covenant is rare in
children we know that everyone knows
that
it's very it's rare that they contract
it it's rare it's even more rare that
they have a severe reaction to it it's
rare that they spread it
all of that is rare they're they're
they're not a high-risk group
so why do they need to take the vaccine
at all why are we doing this at all
for them well we're doing it
to protect the grown-ups and that's why
i've been hammering on this point
this the whole time from from day one
how we've got this completely backwards
over the last uh whatever 14 15 months
we have been requiring
and when i say we i mean like the
universal we as society
we have been requiring our kids to make
sacrifice after sacrifice
for us to keep us safe and to make us
feel better
and i have to amend that because it's
not really to keep us safe and make us
feel better it's to make us feel better
because our safety was never
significantly
uh put it put at risk by kids
running around without masks on
kids wearing masks that doesn't that
doesn't really do much for our own
safety just it just makes us
psychologically feel better
what psychological effect does it have
on the kids who cares it's not about
them it's about us
it's supposed to be what happened to it
should be the exact opposite
what happened to us as grown-ups making
sacrifices for kids
i have also said from the beginning i
will happily
risk getting covered for the sake of not
forcing kids to wear masks
if my own kids had contracted covid
which again would have been a a rare
occurrence but if they had
i was gonna put masks on them and
segregate them from the family if they
got it all right
i had this my wife and i talked with us
early on we said well if they get it
then we're getting it
it's just that's just what it's going to
be
we're not going to lock them in a room
somewhere treat them like rabid animals
and now we're dosing them with this um
with this drug and what's even if you
got the vaccine see no one can explain
this
if the vaccine works if it's effective
then why do you need kids to have to
take it
what are you worried about is it
effective or not
all right next we have sort of play this
for you mitch mcconnell
had brief comments about why
he opposes the so-called voting rights
law from
from democrats and i saw this making the
rounds on social media people were kind
of upset about it
about what he said here but he's exactly
right so here's what he said
there's no threat to the voting rights
law it's
against the law to discriminate in
voting on the base of race
already and so i think it's unnecessary
that's it there's no threat to voting
rights
in america right now and uh
people were upset of course leftists
were upset how dare he
couldn't give an example of
how how are anyone's voting rights on
the line how are anyone's voting rights
being infringed
once you get once you reach voting age
everyone can vote
there's nothing stopping you
it's easier than it's ever been there's
absolutely nothing preventing you
if you're legally eligible to vote
there's nothing preventing you from
doing it
this is one of the biggest strawmans in
the in
you know in political discourse right
now it's about voting rights we have to
protect voting rights what
do we protect voting rights they are
under no threat at
all there are no laws
preventing anyone from voting on the
basis of race in in america in the year
2021 that doesn't exist
a voter id but voter id uh dispropor
really voter id
is a is a is a is a ploy it's a
conspiracy to stop uh black people from
from voting still no one's been able to
explain why can't
so what you're saying a black person
can't get an id you're saying that most
of them don't already have
ids like white people do
you need it to participate in society as
an adult
anyway
i mean i don't know who these adults are
who don't have photo ids but i i don't
know who they are
i never meet them because they wouldn't
really be able to do anything without
one
what can someone give me an example i
want an example show
me uh you know an adult i don't mean
someone that just turned 18 or whatever
show me like uh someone who's 30
okay or 25 and
really wants a photo id and doesn't have
one yet
who who is that person
and whoever it is let us know who that
person is because we can easily explain
to them we can say hey
all you gotta do is go to the dmv
there's definitely a dmv
near you you can easily get there
i don't know who i just don't know who
these i don't know who the people are
who can't find ids or don't know how to
get them
but there is no no threat to uh voting
rights and i say that as you know as
someone who
uh i actually want to restrict voting
rights not on the basis of race
but on the basis of of knowledge
and competency i've been very clear
about that all along i think i think way
fewer people should be voting
and i'm actually in favor of restricting
voting rights
in order to keep ignorances of all races
and sexes out of the voting booths
booth but that that's my
agenda that's what i would like to see
happen there is no support for it
sadly see i'm the guy who wants to do
that and is very open about it
and i can tell you on the right there is
no
really almost no support for my view
especially not for people in power
i am i am way out on a on in the fringes
with uh with with that view
and i fully admit that so
you've got nothing to worry about all
right
number three is from cnn it says chris
harrison is not getting a rose from abc
the show's producer and distributor
warner horizon and abc entertainment
confirmed to cnn tuesday in a joint
statement that the longtime bachelor
franchise host is exiting the show
the statement reads chris harrison is
stepping aside as host of the bachelor
franchise we're thankful for his many
contributions over the past 20 years
i wish him all the best on his new
journey we're thankful but we threw him
onto the bus we destroyed him
we ruined his life in his career uh but
we wish him all the best
it's like you've just trampled this guy
into the ground
and he's laying there his bones are
broken he can't
move he's paralyzed and then you say hey
wish you all the best
harrison announced in february that he
was stepping aside from the show
following controversial remarks well i
don't need to keep
controversial controversial remarks no
i'll i'm not gonna let cnn explain to
you what happened if you don't remember
chris harrison host of the bachelor
uh he he uh
was responding to the
controversy surrounding another a
contestant rachel lindsey
white woman who years prior as a college
student had gone to an antebellum-themed
like old south themed frat party
which have been very common it's not
racist
okay it's not it's there's there's
there's not confederate flags hanging
all over the place
okay this is not a um
it's not a confederacy themed
uh party in fact it's
antebellum means before the war
so um she went to this to this party
not racist at all there was a picture of
it and remember then and then she
there's this big racism controversy and
they were trying to cancel her and
destroy her
all chris harrison does is he in an
interview with uh rachel
oh no rachel kirk cannell now i'm
getting all confused maybe i didn't need
cnn to explain this
rachel kirk canelo is the is the white
uh contestant who got canceled
rachel lindsay is another host and um
chris harrison was in an interview with
rachel lindsay and all he did was defend
kurt canel and say hey you know maybe we
don't need to ruin her life because she
went to a
frat party or sorority party a few years
ago
maybe there's no reason to do that let's
have a little bit of grace and
forgiveness that's what he said
he called for grace and forgiveness and
for that
he had to step down and now he's gone
from the show permanently which i think
we all saw coming
but he's another one
just like uh who is it ellie kemper we
talked about yesterday
both of them i can't really defend them
because they both apologized
and he came out chris harrison came out
just groveling
and begging for forgiveness even though
he had done nothing wrong at all
he still loses his job anyway and
they're not done so cnn
on news that chris harrison was stepping
down cnn decided to dance on his grave
and uh don lemon brought rachel lindsay
the bachelor host
who had the who had the initial
interview with chris harrison where he
defended rachel canal
brought her in and they just decided to
you know
to spit on him a little bit more while
he's down let's watch that
what did you think when you heard chris
harrison make this distinction between
attending
an old south antebellum theme party in
2018
versus now i mean 2018 was just like
yesterday we had
charlottesville had happened in 2018 we
had racial reckoning
in america in 2018 as if it was somehow
okay then
well we had racist issues on the show in
2017 there was a race
racist contestant casted for my season
in 2018
uh the lead picked someone who had who
was liking racist xenophobic transphobic
homophobic things on social media
so we've dealt with this within the
franchise so my
initial reaction was i was shocked i
thought maybe he misspoke
but then when he continued down this
path i thought oh no
this is really what he wants to say and
i felt
i needed to let him say it why do you
think
chris harrison was willing to give
rachel kirk connell so much room for
her hurtful actions yet couldn't muster
and empathy towards communities
of color who were offended or even to
you in that interview and
correct me if i'm wrong seemingly as if
trying to
teach you something or um
i mean just go on
well i think that's the problem in our
society is that
people aren't trying to understand the
other side
people aren't trying to understand the
other side
unlike you rachel right you really
wanted to understand his point of view
she wanted to understand his point of
view so so much that she was
shocked that he would even have a point
of view
that differs from her own that's what
you're getting is that both
both rachel and don there are they're
they're flabbergasted
they're almost speechless still
now months later they haven't gotten
over the emotional trauma
caused by the fact that this guy had a
had a point of view that slightly
differed from theirs and only slightly
because he wasn't even defending he he
wasn't going as far as i'm going right
now
really really extreme you know i'm i'm
i would flat out say there's nothing
wrong with the party she went to
that's what i would say he didn't even
say that
he wasn't defending the party in fact he
kept he kept hedging and
and uh all of that he's very circumspect
about it
and he kept he kept saying over and over
again i'm not defending it i would never
defend it i'm not saying
i just all i'm saying is maybe we have a
little grace of forgiveness that was his
only
so it's a slight slight divergence
from from their own view
and that he would even diverge slightly
i mean rachel lindsay said it she was
she was sitting there shocked just
speechless
are you are you telling me this white
man is daring
to disagree with me i can't believe it
well clearly we have to destroy his life
that's what she decided to do
and as much as i would like to defend
chris harrison just because i
detest this kind of thing
and i think rachel lindsay obviously is
a vile
vile evil person and i don't think
that's going overboard when you
look when you just destroy someone's
life for no reason
no reason at all just to exert your own
power
and influence and just so you can
position yourself as the victim yeah
that is evil
behavior so on that basis i'd like to
defend chris harris but i can't because
he groveled and apologized
and it got him nothing
and i can keep on saying this and it
won't matter because people will keep on
doing it
but he might as well you see it's too
late now see he's he's
he's already admitted guilt he lost his
job
he's admitted basically that he's a
racist even though he isn't
yet would he have lost his job if he had
come out from beginning and said
you know what i didn't say anything
wrong how dare
all of you you all owe me an apology
rachel lindsay you disgusting
brat you know what you're doing
i demand you apologize to me
now if he had said that would he have
lost his job yes would he have lost it a
lot quicker
absolutely but he was losing it anyway
and at least there he has his dignity
and also he can continue to
you know he has not admitted guilt
but it won't matter um this is just for
for someone like chris harrison
especially living in the world that he
does
it it's in it's instinctive to apologize
the moment he sees that he's losing
social acceptance
which is the thing that he craves most
of all even more than money and his job
and everything
what he wants is to be socially accepted
and uh
and he clings on to that all these
people do and the moment he sees that
slipping through his fingers he he says
whatever he thinks he needs to say
to maintain some chance of social
acceptance
and it's all for not it's all for
nothing
all right let's see um
i think we had one more here if i can
find it
okay for the daily wire it says a uh
luden county virginia oh
and eventually i'll figure out how to
actually pronounce is it loud i think
it's loudon okay
lewden lewden county virginia um a
loudoun county virginia elementary
school teacher who was placed on
administrative leave in may for refusing
to affirm transgender identity children
was reinstated by a judge on tuesday
byron tanner cross who teaches physical
education at leesburg elementary school
secured a temporary injunction
from judge james plowman in his lawsuit
against
loudoun county public schools according
to an announcement from
alliance defending freedom which
defended him
adf tweeted quote tanner cross a
virginia elementary school teacher an
adf client who's suspended for raising
concerns to the board
of a proposed gender policy has won a
temporary injunction
and the judge has ordered his
reinstatement a massive victory
for freedom of speech i would only
offer one correction it's not just a
victory for freedom of speech it's a
victory for
for truth for science for sanity all
those things that i said we should be
conserving it's a victory for that
um local wtop reporter
neil oginstein augenstein reported that
plowman
found the school system's suspension was
unconstitutional
and its handling of the situation was
vindictive yeah you think
the school argued that it suspended
cross not for his beliefs but because of
the disruption he allegedly caused
but plowman said there was simply an
absence of evidence that any disruption
to school operations
took place and yeah if it does just
disrupt school
operations it's because you have decided
to operate the school around this
anti-science anti-truth totally insane
gender theory thing
if if if a teacher simply affirming
that boys or boys and girls or girls
disrupts operation
that tells me something about the way
that the school's being operated
but now he's being reinstated so i
wanted to highlight that story as a nice
little contrast
okay in one case you have a guy he
didn't do anything wrong
grovels and apologizes loses his job
loses everything loses respect loses
social acceptance loses everything he
wants
he he gives up his dignity and uh
and in exchange gets nothing in return
the very next story you have someone
who also did nothing wrong faced
consequences for it
rather than apologizing rather than
coming out it's like oh gee
you know come to think of it uh i guess
yeah i guess sometimes boys are girls
silly me i'm so sorry for my transphobia
rather than doing that which is what
most people do
we have this teacher who's fighting back
he's saying hell no
this is not going to happen i'll take
you to court
and for now he's he's winning
and even if he doesn't ultimately win i
mean even if ultimately he gets uh
he loses the job with all said and done
and all the
and you know this has made its way
through all the courts and everything
still you know he would have lost his
job anyway
but now he retains his dignity and he's
and he's fighting for truth and he's
doing the right thing
and he's sending a message that you know
what not
everybody is going to slink away quietly
finally quick bonus thing i just wanted
to show you an indiana jones twitter
account or something unofficial account
i think
had a picture from i didn't even know
this was a thing that was happening i
can't say i'm surprised but
they had a picture from the set of
indiana jones five
and the tweet says exclusive photo we
got right now
there's the picture harrison ford cited
on the set of indiana jones five
look at that picture how depressing is
this
harrison how old is there harrison ford
is like 80 years old
almost i think so you've had this old
kind of shriveled man
wearing a wearing a face mask outside
presumably is already vaccinated
indiana jones now elderly and wearing
them and too afraid to walk outside
without a mask
just let it go like indiana jones the
first three movies were entertaining it
was an
entertaining story entertaining idea
it let it go
but you know what just like
conservatives will keep going to burger
king for whatever reason
and they'll let their kids watch uh
nickelodeon
people are gonna file into the theater
or at least go on streaming to watch
this
joke of a movie to watch an 80 year old
indiana jones
fighting bad guys we all complain about
this kind of stuff
the the never-ending sequels and they
just they run these franchises into the
ground
we complain about it that people still
watch the movies so as long as we watch
them they're going to keep churning them
out
all right let's go now to um reading the
youtube comments
says there was something so unnatural
about hearing matt utter the words
my sweet babies anthony says matt
calling all of us sweet babies gave me
ptsd
but then another comment says okay so
matt's fan base is officially known as
the sweet baby gang
i i guess i can't really tell
anyone else how to identify themselves
if you want to be the sweet baby gang
you can
be yeah you know what let's go with that
just
just to really confuse everybody who
doesn't listen to the show
hearing people who are fans of the show
identify themselves as a sweet baby gang
and the agreement we have to make is
that we never explain to anyone where
that
comes from or why
bo 7341 says matt you're usually on
point but you miss the trump desantis
thing if trump builds up the trump
desantis 2024 momentum right now it'll
hand desantis the nomination when trump
announces he's not running in 2023
meanwhile the mainstream media will stay
focused on trump instead of targeting
desantis
if that's the goal with the talk of
trump desantis 2024
then great okay i just really don't
think that is the goal
um i don't think trump is going to do
that
for someone else
you know trump offering himself sort of
as a human shield
for some other guy so that he can take
the reins
that would be great if trump would do
that kind of thing but
trump doesn't do those kinds of things
so um
no i don't i don't think that's the i
also i don't think that trump the santus
the trump standard stick is actually
going to happen because i don't think
desantis would do that it would be a
terrible idea for him
but i also i i your interpretation i'm
not sure i quite agree with
trail price says in your ideal world you
wouldn't have factory farms how do you
define these factory farms and what
exactly do you think they're getting
wrong
i have utmost respect for our farmers
and ranchers they're the stewards of the
environment and they take pride in
producing high quality food
and enjoy uh and and enough to feed the
world
well that's why i said ideal world
you know and we talked about greater
thunderberg or or any of these
environmentalists
they don't draw any distinction between
an ideal world and first of all a lot of
their ideals i don't share
in many cases their ideal world is a
dystopian nightmare
but even some of their objectives that i
agree with they don't have any
any discernible practical plan for
getting there i mean the green new deal
is a perfect example of that most of the
stuff that the green new deal wants to
do
is bad but even the goals that could be
good there's no practical way of getting
there
so that's why i'm talking it's just
totally it's an ideal world in an ideal
world
uh yeah it'd be it'd be we would have a
lot of small kind of mom and pop farms
and that's how we would be living and it
would be
it would be a simple life and all of
that i could see that as ideal but
that's just not the world we live in
and again we have 330 million people in
this country
who have to eat
and finally opossum says sometimes i
wake up and realize i'm out of coffee
and i
still go to the grocery store in my pjs
i feel no shame
well you should feel shame we
we have all done it i mean we've all
left the house looking like slobs
not bothering to get changed but you
should feel shame about it
i think we all spend way too much time
sitting we can all agree with that and
sometimes our job requires us to do
quite a lot of sitting um
but if you've got to sit this much you
should really think about the kind of
chair
you're sitting in it can make a lot of
health not a lot of the difference not
only to your to your uh
to your comfort but also to your health
and that's why you need x chair x chair
has you covered for your office chair
needs the secret is not only their
patented dynamic variable lumbar support
which offers unbelievable lumbar
support to your lower back but now
thanks to their xhmt technology
you get heat and massage therapy while
you're just sitting at your desk
instead of your old uncomfortable office
chair that has i probably doesn't have
heat and massage therapy i'm assuming
now you can look forward to spending
hours sitting in the ultimate
therapeutic massager
you got to try this chair out for
yourself the xh mt hmt delivers
heat and massage technology right to
your core helping increase blood flow
muscle recovery and energy like i said
it's about not just comfort but health
as well
x chair is on sale now for 100 off so go
to xchairwalsh.com now that's the letter
x chairwalsh.com
or call one eight four four four extra
extra has a 30-day guarantee
of complete comfort and you could
finance your purchase for as little as
30 bucks a month
go to xchairwalsh.com and use code x
wheels for free x-wheel bladecasters
that's xchairwalsh.com
also you know as the daily wire grows uh
so does the amount of
theocratic fascist content that i get to
put out that's what i'm so excited about
which is why it's crucial that you don't
miss any of it it might seem like a tall
order but it's actually pretty easy to
keep up when you have the daily wire app
on you at all times it's where you'll
find
genius political commentary like my con
my podcasts and my content than the
other shows too
which are also almost as genius we also
have new investigative journalism
which which i think is great i'm excited
about that big tech sports coverage from
our writers as well
even if you're not a daily wire
subscriber you'll be the first to know
what's trending with uh mobile
notifications
for the latest news and all of your
favorite content only a touch away so
download the daily wire app
and stay up to speed with the freshest
conservative voices around no matter
where you are
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today we cancel national geographic i
mean really we could cancel national
geographic simply for rebranding itself
as nat geo a few years ago and shifting
all of its television programming over
to reality shows
the national geographic channel should
be nothing but nature documentaries and
documentaries about primitive tribes
people in the amazon
that's all anyone ever wanted from
national geographic
they don't want whatever nachio gives us
now and what they give us now includes a
heavy dose of far left
racial propaganda of course the most
recent and egregious example of this is
something called the race card
project which the company recently
unveiled to give you an idea of the tone
and tenor of this thing the editor of
national geographic
susan goldberg recently sent out a mass
email to readers
promoting the project and she signed the
email quote
sincerely susan goldberg editor-in-chief
national geographic
race card white privileged with much to
learn
so here she is literally playing the
race card but for a white person playing
the race card means apologizing
non-white people can play the race card
in order to gain
sympathy and privilege white people can
play it in order to be further demeaned
and degraded and as we've discovered
many white people in this country have a
masochistic
fetish for that sort of thing so they're
more than happy to play the card
and accept that treatment as for the
race card project itself nachio uh
rolled it out on twitter
and uh here's what it says it says 10
years ago michelle norris launched the
race card project which asks people to
describe their feelings on race at just
six words
she thought few would respond here are
some of the responses out of half a
million so far
that she's received and from there
nachio highlights several people of
different races who describe their
lived experience to use the leftist term
in six words
um we'll go through some of these that
they highlight
first we have a black man osias uh
maritab who says
black boy white world perpetually
exhausted
and we're told that his parents came
here from ethiopia and you'd think that
he'd be quite grateful to be in this
country living a life of comparative
luxury and privilege
and not in ethiopia but no he's
exhausted
so exhausted it's exhausting living in a
first world country well-fed
with all with access to all of life's
comforts and luxuries it's so exhausting
just exhausted all the time then we have
mark quarles who's a black man who
chooses these six words with kids i'm
dead
alone thug also there's hannah peoples
who says
i am not an exotic creature hannah is
not white but we aren't told what her
ethnic identity is apparently the fact
that people can't
look at her and immediately know her
country of origin is its own form of
persecution we're told quote
hannah people said that constant
guessing game about her identity as well
as the harassment and unwanted attention
she's received from creepy men make her
feel like a specimen
her six-word story was born of
exasperation
exhausted exasperated
then we have gene tagaban who's a native
american who says
native americans america's invisible
invisible
invisible this one struck me as a little
bit lazy
i mean he's given six words and he can
only think of three so he repeats one
three times so it's got like native
americans america
native americans america is invisible no
actually you get six words oh okay well
uh
then america's invisible invisible
invisible
there are a few white people featured
but compare their self-description
with the descriptions offered by the
minority participants
white guy daniel robbins says ashamed
that accomplished minorities surprised
me
he's given six words to describe his
experience as a white man and
one of the six he chooses is ashamed
same for lindsay heydrich who's a white
woman who says i'm ashamed for my
ancestors race apparently she had
ancestors who were slave owners she's
she's ashamed
not of their behavior but of their race
and her own the only commonality between
all these responses
is that everyone is dejected and sad and
complaining
they're all living in the most
prosperous and freest country in world
history they're all
unimaginably privileged when compared to
almost everyone else who has ever lived
anywhere on earth
they're all clothed and fed and doing
fine and yet their perception of their
experience
is completely negative for the minority
respondents
they're angry about the alleged
persecution they suffer at the hands of
whites
although none of them can give a
compelling example of persecution one of
them is annoyed
because people can't guess her ethnicity
on sight
and the other guy's exhausted because
although life is a hell of a lot better
than it would be in ethiopia
it still isn't perfect and the lack of a
perfect life is exhausting
meanwhile the white people are ashamed
ashamed of themselves even though they
can't really explain
what they've done wrong so just think
about this the minorities are sure
that white people are doing them wrong
but can't explain how
the white people are sure that they've
done wrong but can't explain what
they've done wrong
everyone is sad everyone is mad only the
white people are ashamed
and nobody knows why they feel any of
this
it's all quite sick and gross and
perverse and it shows you to what extent
many in the american public have been
brainwashed this is one of the most
telling signs of brainwashing
when people hold firm often
self-destructive beliefs but they can't
explain
why they hold those beliefs it also
shows us that our culture is suffering
from i think a cataclysmic crisis of
meaning
while our comfort has increased and our
collective wealth and luxury
has also increased we've turned from god
we've turned from traditional faith
and we have found our lives empty and
purposeless because of it
i mean that's the real reason why people
are so sad and depressed and riddled
with anxiety that they can't explain
but the left's racial dogma gives people
a framework for understanding that
anxiety it's the wrong framework
but a person without meaning a person
without purpose will grasp on
to anything that seems solid and
intelligible
even if only superficially intelligible
because this is all the result of
brainwashing it's probably useless to
engage with it intellectually but i i
will anyway
just on this one point the idea that
white people should be ashamed of their
whole race
because of the past bad bad behaviors of
some white people
is completely insane even if white
people were uniquely evil in history it
still wouldn't make sense to be ashamed
or apologetic for your race
you don't inherit guilt and sin through
skin pigment
your great-great-great-grandfather's
sins are not your own
even if his skin color is but as it
happens
and this is very crucial to understand
white people were most definitely
not uniquely evil in history
what after all are the evils that white
people are supposed to be
so ashamed about slavery
conquest genocide racism
well first of all conquest isn't always
a bad thing sometimes it's a good thing
for one civilization to be conquered by
another i gave the example last week of
the aztecs who themselves conquered and
slaved
their tributary states and forced them
to provide fodder often women and
children for human sacrifice
there's a reason why when the spanish
came here they were able to easily
enlist
neighboring tribes to defeat the aztecs
think about that you've got these
strange creatures who have landed from
an unknown land
um and uh the the the other native
american tribes
many of them easily quickly fell in with
the spanish
and said yeah we want to help you take
these people down
everyone hated the aztecs because they
were a brutal murderous
dictatorial regime but the point is that
however you feel about conquest whites
did not invent it
we didn't even introduce it to this side
of the world
white people didn't introduce slavery or
racism either
these are humanity's sins they've been
practiced or committed
by all people everywhere through all
history
the the unique thing about the united
states relationship with slavery is that
we abolished it in less than a century
whereas some parts of the world
many of them non-what non-white took
millennia to do the same some people
still have not effectively gotten rid of
the practice
as for racism racism again is a foible
of humanity
all humanity across time
and it is today far more prominent and
far more accepted and far more
mainstream
in non-western countries
if white people should be ashamed then
everyone
everywhere should be ashamed all the
time
either that or we can all move on with
our lives
and we can deal with the present and we
can let the past remain where it belongs
whatever choice we make as far as that
goes
the one choice that i certainly can make
today at least
is to say to national geographic you're
canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin
stevens production manager pavel vadosky
the show is edited by sasha tulmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show joe
biden's beloved son is in hot water
again
after messages show him using the n-word
but it's fine he showbiden's son will be
fine that's today on the ben shapiro
show give it a listen
you